a warm round of applause
we need headphones of mr. Zimmerman's
and go yes
instead vanish okay perfecto million was
not have you mean you don't so welcome
it's a pleasure to have you here with us
it's a privilege and an honor and
yesterday we met two hundred young
people making proposals this Green Deal
so we picked our three key ideas that
are resulted from the worker groups yeah
we have a summary of all these ideas so
they came up with three ideas we thought
could have a greater impact and in a few
minutes we're going to present these are
three ideas and we note that the Green
Deal was approved yesterday and I'd like
to ensign tan apart to know a little bit
would like to know a little bit more
about this Green Deal this way this way
but the guys are sitting there okay I'll
try and I'll try and do everything okay
I'm very excited to be able to present
to you very briefly the green new deal
for Europe but I have to say one thing
before I do that if we did not have
your movements being active over the
last two years today I am sure I would
not be able to present a green new deal
thank you so much for all your support
and it is my biggest wish it is my
biggest wish that you would see the
Green Deal as your deal it is my biggest
wish that you are part of translating
what is a road map into concrete
measures for the next generation the
Green Deal can help us achieve this very
important goal which is to be climate
neutral as a continent by 2050 we need
to do this because if we don't engage on
this road the rise of the temperature is
going to be way beyond 1.5 degrees and
then the situation is quite literally
out of control we then as human beings
can no longer control events and that my
friends is a scary thought already now
we see what erratic weather is doing
already now we see that Mother Earth can
no longer support the way we behave
we're in the country that has
experienced this very directly with the
gotough RIA that has caused the deaths
that is caused used devastation which is
an erratic weather form huge storms that
used to happen in Spain perhaps once
every 50 years and now Spain has to be
prepared to have a gotough react perhaps
once or even more often every year so we
need to make sure we take control of our
destiny by implementing the Green Deal
and I want to emphasize that it's a road
map it's not a precise prescription but
that road map
includes proposals for all areas that
are affected which is in fact all of
society it has proposals on agriculture
and I'm sure we're going to be talking
about that a bit more in a moment
it had has proposals on our mobility on
our energy sector it has proposals on
how we build on has proposals to do a
lot of reforestation to make our
continent and our cities greener again
and it has proposals to reset our
industrial set up so that our economy is
a sustainable economy with sustainable
jobs for everyone let me end on one note
which I want to share with you if we
want this to succeed we can leave no one
behind because the people who are most
vulnerable in climate change are also
the people who very often feel that they
are most vulnerable in the Green Deal in
the sense that the transition we are
asking from them is something they fear
they can make they can't afford to do
that they don't know where to go so
paradoxically if we are not careful the
people who are most vulnerable through
climate change might be the people who
will stop us take the measures we need
to address climate change for this not
to happen we need to make sure that this
transformation is also done on a
socially sound basis that we protect the
weakest in our society and we take along
those who have so much to lose so that
they become winner winners in this new
society you guys are going to decide
whether this is going to happen or not
you guys have made us do this until now
and you guys will decide whether we will
successful in implementing all that we
need to do Thanks
[Applause]
muchisimas gracias and West thank you
very much
yesterday we were developing many ideas
and proposals because there are many
proposals we won't be able to present
today so I'd like to ask those of you
who had taken photographs to please
share them in social media there are
hash tags etc so please make sure you
load them so that we can share them and
now would like to welcome those are
three people that have been voted by
everybody so I'm going to ask you to
please come up
and tenemos otra mitad or follow I guess
we have another microphone or else L
will use mr. Timmerman's microphone
first of all I'd like to hand the floor
over to Rodrigo Lopez begin from the
biosphere reserves from UNESCO in Spain
and he's going to present his idea in
about three minutes in order to
elaborate on yesterday's experience and
about the development of their proposal
first of all mr. Timmerman's I'd like to
thank you for allowing Arthur Young to
participate in governor's decisions and
in decisions made on the level of the
European Union we believe that
protecting biodiversity will help us
fight climate change and we believe that
we must be able to live in our own
territories and this is what our
proposal has to do with sustainable food
plan we work in a network and I'm going
to tell you about a successful challenge
in the North that we're trying to share
with 700 reserves that are places for
experimental activities in this area
first of all because we want to fight
climate change high percentage of
greenhouse effects come emissions come
from our activities many European
citizens don't have access to decent
food and foods when they cover larger
distances are collected that before they
are ripe and I believe that it is
extremely important to be able to
collect them locally instead of
resorting to chemicals adapt them so our
food is going to taste and with more
nutrients I know
goal 11 responsible production and
consume consumption when we consume
locally and money stays inside the
European Union it doesn't leak out and
it stays in our own villages in our
towns the better neighbors do the more
we strengthen our productive systems and
also life or land ecosystems in my
territory we see that people abandon
villages because when we no longer fun
we see invading species and people start
to planting trees like eucalyptus they
produce terrible problems in the soil
and we have to turn the situation around
and this is what we want to do this is
what our proposal is about to
incentivize consumption locally to
incentivize local shops so we thought
about creating a label for these are
products that somehow justify and that
prove that they come from local
productions thank you very much now
we're going to listen to everybody and
perhaps you may also have a question for
the rest
I'd like to invite Anna Maria over in
order to share their proposal and I'd
like to please ask you to slow down and
Anna come from University of alcalá
thank you very much first of all for
inviting us and for giving us the
opportunity to share our ideas and
proposals so
like to say that we could change the
focus on environmental education because
it is true that much of what we need to
do is focused on children and schools
but this is a problem that can be shared
by older people by alpha with adults
because they are the ones who act so
people who can do something on the level
of companies well I believe that
training is essential not only this
scientific and reliable education that
professionals may teach and disseminate
so it's a lifelong education at any age
and on the level of schools and
non-formal education and even companies
because if we start making people aware
of what is happening that will be a huge
uh step because if we do so the rest of
the actions will follow because if we
know what is happening we'll know what
to do but of course we lack the
education so I propose to improve what
we do in education and whatever we are
not doing well must be amended and
therefore improve thank you very much
and now we have a Victor Cortez Ortega
who studies experimental science at Rey
Juan Carlos the University of Madrid
good morning and thank you very much for
allowing us to be here with you because
this may be a bridge between these two
domains that operate separately my
proposal has to do with increase our
with increasing our investment in R&D
because science we are not capable of
improving from a technological and
scientific standpoint we won't be able
to implement our proposals and this is
why we collected the series of proposals
we believe to be a key among which is
the following
until technology can solve the problem
of renewables we could use nuclear
energy but as a basis but using waste in
order to avoid this problem and from the
point of view of you also we propose to
encourage the use of biofuels like
kerosene or other fuels used in aviation
and the ideas to reduce their emissions
but those emissions that we are going to
keep on producing we need to get rid of
them in order to do this we need to be
able to capture and store co2 in order
to avoid greenhouse effect emissions and
many groups have spoken about this but I
like to speak about pollution it's not
just the atmosphere or cities that are
polluted but also rivers and soil and we
need to start doing research on soil
remediation but we need to restructure
our territories our land are the same
too
so therefore my proposal and the one
we've discussed is that of creating a
European scientific platform that will
bring together all research institutions
universities and other scientific
centers that will bring us together
in order to be able to communicate and
share ideas and to have a better project
funding and to this and we need to
increase our investments in R&D and I
but not just on a European level but
also on the world level and this is
something that can be created through a
European legislation people always think
about the lack of funds for research
projects and without these are funds we
can not make progress and I'd like to
end by saying that science is the mother
of a progress
science has globalized as it's brought
us together and it will also bring us
out of these problems because without
science amo wouldn't be sapiens for us
implemented Varick here and and it well
let's ask let's see show of hands who
was in the workshop yesterday the people
who developed these proposals look at
them they developed all these ideas
together maybe you have a question for
them perhaps to see how yesterday went
yes ok let me start with you
we were talk we talked a lot about the
missions and about the climate crisis
linked to this crisis intimately linked
to this crisis is a biodiversity crisis
we are at the risk of losing 1 million
species because of the way we live and
this is intimately linked with the
climate crisis and we need to find
solutions one of the solutions a very
important part of the solution is in
recreating agriculture in making
agriculture sustainable in helping our
farming community to rid itself of the
necessity of so many pesticides in
creating opportunities for the farming
community to increase biodiversity to be
part of reforestation in Europe to find
solutions which are based in the natural
environment and people are citizens we
want healthy foods healthy foods that we
have today and we have to find a program
to redirect our agricultural policy in
that direction today everybody is
unhappy the farmers are unhappy because
they get little money for their produce
consumers are unhappy because the
quality isn't good enough and people are
unhappy because it leads to natural
degradation instead of improving our
natural environment so the Commission
will present early next year
from farm to fork where we will take all
these elements into consideration to
redirect our Common Agricultural Policy
and to give a better future for farmers
who want to be sustainable and I suggest
that when we make these plans we ask you
to send your contribution to see if we
can incorporate some of your ideas in
the plans we have made okay then moving
to the two subjects which are related
your two subjects are related many of
the solutions we can find do not need
new science some of the solutions need a
lot of new science so we need to invest
in scientific research more than we have
done so far but we also need to help the
scientific community to translate what
they have found into practical solutions
in cooperation with industry with
society that's what the role the
Commission will see we also need to
create possibilities for investment so
that startups very often with young
people of your age who want to bring new
products to the market who want to
incorporate this climate positive
science into their business gets
supports get loans gets subsidies so
that they can start their companies and
create jobs and incorporate science into
them but I want to make a more
fundamental point quickly because it's
very important perhaps most important
point why are you asked
because you were educated to know
critical thinking you looked at the
facts and you said we can't go on like
this and you demanded of us politicians
that reacts for this you need good
education if you don't have good
education you don't learn critical
thinking and then populist and
charlatans can sell you anything you
will believe anything so we need to make
sure that our educational system still
delivers young people that are capable
of critical thinking and that young
people who are capable of critical
thinking come to the right conclusions
about climate change and then use that
knowledge to spread it in wider society
and we as commission have to help you
provide you with the information provide
you with a means of communication so
that your knowledge can be spread in
wider society and this brings me to my
final point I am talking today to your
generation but the part of your
generation who is engaged in this and
I'm asking you to do one thing please
please please keep talking to other
members of your generation who do not
feel part of this who feel excluded or
don't believe it yet or are against it
who are sort of weaponized by people who
want to use them in a political battle
that will not help us solve this problem
so let's feel a collective
responsibility to take everyone along
and to leave no one behind also in your
generation thank you so much for your
contributions
[Applause]
maybe I once again my office stands if
you want to be part of the policy
framing that we're good policy
formulation that we're going to do I
invite the three of you to be part of
that and through you let me say one
thing we are going to create a climate
pact and your generation has to have a
role in that climate pact you have to be
heard your ideas have to be brought
along and I will promise to you that you
will be heard and that you will be part
of the climate pact
[Applause]
Aaron el momento vamos tener la
posibilidad para tomar preguntas de
todos los otros understand okay mmm in a
minute we'll have see c'mon c'mon sido
para nosotros experiencia they are yet
as Sierra pin success university plays
Paseos Hamas 0s experiencia we were
never meant yeah yo creo que hace whom
would well I believe it was a greatly
enriching it was a an interesting
experience to get together with another
200 people to debate these matters and
relay them directly face-to-face I
believe we should have more of this and
in some my messages you need to the you
need to trust the youths and we may make
mistakes we're all in tunnel 2 making
mistakes but you need to listen to us
and that's why I'm so grateful that you
decided to listen to us and what was it
like for you well I agree with him
yesterday was an awesome experience
everyone had an idea or something to
contribute
but just as we contributed ideas
yesterday there will be new ideas next
year because everything is in motion and
ideas they're updated and I believe that
it's very important for everyone to
express their ideas and their opinions
and the interest of the greater good
we company rose Paris occasionally from
Utah I honestly don't know what to say
I'm grateful that we're finally being
heard but not just year I believe we
need to be heard in the academic world
because there's a plenty of knowledge
out there and young people have plenty
of ideas and plans for the future but
they don't know how to get there how to
turn them into action so we need to make
our voices heard in other areas trust me
it's worth it well thank you thanks
everyone
so I would like to ask everyone for big
round of applause for these three youths
and to all of you for all the good work
thank you once more well the floor is
open for questions or comments
good morning my name is Andrea okay I'm
standing up my name is Andrea and I have
a request for you and for the entire EC
in charge of this new Green Deal Europe
cannot continue to say that our
emissions have been produced Europe
cannot continue to say that its
emissions have been reduced as while
they continue to do business with
industries and countries that are
serious pollutants of the environment we
need to be transparent we need to tell
the truth growth and pollution in Europe
are linked and we need real indicators
of this connection in this Green Deal we
cannot continue to import goods from
polluting industries I believe that's
the only way we can actually drive or
motivate other countries that have not
joined her the Paris Convention to join
our efforts that's the driver we need to
motivate or force non-compliant nations
into this deal because we're all on this
ship together it's not just Europe all
the points and let me answer directly in
the Green Deal we've also changed our
trade policy we have said that if Europe
negotiates trade deals with other parts
of the world the principles of achieving
the goals of the Paris agreements are an
integral part if the trade partner
doesn't subscribe to that there will be
no trade deal so that is how we are
trying to help our trade partners
also to go in the same direction on top
of that I believe European consumers
should be aware of the products they put
on their plates or they buy in the shops
and many of the agricultural products we
import are obtained through
deforestation of primal forests and I
want European consumers to be aware so
that at the end of the day when you go
to a shop and you buy a product that you
are know that you're not contributing to
deforestation to the disappearance of
the Amazonas or deforestation in other
parts of the world so also in that we
will have to make steps forward at the
end of the day trade has to be fair
because you are so right we can do
whatever we like in Europe if we don't
help other parts of the world walk the
same walk and then we were not going to
achieve what we want because at the end
of the day Europe is only 9% of
emissions our efforts will only help if
we can convince others to do the same
that is an essential element of the
Green Deal it's not yes master do every
window did we have any other questions
you for instance yes hello thanks for
coming my name is Miguel and I'm a
forest engineer you spoke of
reforestation and deforestation my
concern is that about politicians and
many celebrities have their picture
taken when they do reforestation and
then they forget about the extra 80
years it takes for those trees to grow
so I'm suggesting a shared forestry
policy just as we have a common
agricultural policy I suggest that we
create a common policy to give money to
all those forest owners that contribute
to circular economy and who are of the
essence to a reforested
our rural areas through EU policy common
agriculture polish structural policy
Portugal Portugal was incentivized over
many years to plant eucalyptus plants
very close together on huge areas and
one of the reasons of these tremendous
terrible forest fires in Portugal was
exactly this and if we want to have a
massive program of reforestation in
Europe it has to be done on scientific
grounds and with a long-term perspective
we have to listen to the people who know
what they're doing and to put the right
trees in the right place
you know that forests now in Spain and
elsewhere are already suffering terribly
because of the increase of temperature
so we need to offer forests relief by
planting plants in those forests that
can survive and thrive with higher
temperatures and we need to especially
use your expertise to green our cities
you know that every year more than
400,000 Europeans die prematurely
because of bad air quality very often in
cities if we green the cities we improve
the air quality we bring the temperature
down and we create carbon sink apart
from the fact that we create much nicer
cities so we need people with your
expertise to help us make a huge program
that we will plant in the coming years
at least 2 billion trees in Europe this
is what we need to do but you are so
right we need to do it correctly
scientifically and with the expertise of
foresters such as yourself and with a
view to 80 100 years
not just one or two years palooka check
master me everyone you guys honest lady
thank you do we have any other questions
yes hello I propose that governments I
propose that governments both national
and international as well as European
institutions lead by example so that all
the energy you work with should come
from renewable non-polluting sources
beyond that I believe you should also
give European officials the possibility
to move around in the least polluting
possible form of transportation hybrid
at the least and I also believe that
public service is provided both by
States and European institutions should
a guaranteed minimum pollution that's it
thank you it's what we are doing at home
as a family you know looking at the car
and through this is not a good car we
need to get another car looking at how
we go places whether we could use the
bike a bit more than we already do what
we put what sort of food do we put on
the table what we buy and so so there's
a very I think this is going on
everywhere in the world and especially
in Europe people rethinking these things
but we need to give the good example you
are absolutely right and that is why we
also announced announced yesterday that
the Commission has the ambition
of being carbon neutral climate neutral
by 2030 and we will start now looking at
our travel looking at our paper use
looking at our buildings looking at our
catering looking at all these things
that have an influence on our carbon
footprint and we invite the other
European institutions to do the same
thing we invite Member States to do the
same thing and if we do all that because
of course you have to practice what you
preach but we have also to recognize now
I'm the first to recognize this I'm way
way off the mark today and I also will
make it you have to make a lot of
efforts before I can say that my carbon
footprint is acceptable and I think this
applies to many of us but as an
institution we've made this commitment
yesterday and we hope to be able to
convince other institutions and member
states to do the same YES on this event
I must be with us but I know throw lado
but I keep thank you can we go over to
the other side people are willing and
eager to participate on this site as
well
hello good morning my question goes back
to the very first question we heard that
with the new Green Deal new trade
agreements assigned from here on after
will have to be compliant with the Green
Deal in terms of sustainability and
climate change etc but what about old
deals what about old treaties are we
sticking to that tree is like Mercker
sewer the Japan agreement etc we have to
operate obviously is pacta sunt savanna
if you if you've reached the agreement
you honor that agreement but you can
also offer to renegotiate the agreement
to revisit the agreement now you
mentioned one which is makisu makisu
already has possibilities to discuss
issues such as sustainability such as
the management of natural resources etc
and I I also had a meeting with
indigenous peoples from Brazil not so
long ago and I made the pledge to them
that we will use every possibility in
this agreement to also look after the
plight of indigenous people and their
natural environments so we will make
this a very important part of our
discussion with Brazil and other
countries parties to that treaty so we
can already use the possibilities and
treaties better than we have done before
and we will do that just as yes
can musta knee up it in with us thank
you
any further questions around the stage
flowers and I'd really like to ask you
if you think it's possible and if so how
to decarbonize our economies and ship to
renewable energy sources which we all
agree is necessary while still
maintaining and restoring biodiversity
because wind turbines solar power and
biofuels require vast amounts of land I
think it is absolutely possible because
the way we use the land today is so
erratic and so badly planned that we
waste a lot of land wind energy I think
is going to be most successful offshore
so it will not take a lot of that
solar panels increasingly technology
advances we can start integrating solar
panels and so many things in the roof of
cars in windows in in in the tiles on
the roof of buildings everywhere so you
would not need necessarily to use land
that is necessary for our biodiversity
and by the way you know if we succeed in
this program we have of reforestation of
Europe we contribute immensely to
revitalizing our biodiversity if we
succeed in reducing pesticides in taking
endocrine disrupters out of the picture
in making sure that we have a more
bio-based economy we can certainly
increase our biodiversity but it will
remain a huge challenge and it will need
really government action on all levels
municipal regional national European
global and it will not happen without
you telling us to do it and keeping on
our case because otherwise people say
it's too complicated but I think we
could do it and the one thing I would
propose we need to prepare for the big
biodiversity conference that will be
held in China next year and I hope you
will be part of that preparation and
keep us on edge and tell us what to do
so that we do the right things there
next year thank you
did I see some other hand raised up over
there Berger I have a question about the
educational aspect of climate change
over the past decades education around
any topic has changed through the
internet there is a lot of free content
high quality content and video forum
text forum about many things that I
think is often better than the way
schools presented is there any plan
to provide climate change education in
these new formats rather than just
adding books to what students learn in
school
are there any innovative approaches to
education in this regard
thank you well I think we need to use
your expertise and your generation the
way we communicate is already better
than in the past but it's still very
much old school you're right by the way
I'm very proud of the communication
we've prepared and on the Green Deal but
it need it's again on leaflets and you
can watch it online you can go to the
website etc it's all there but what we
need to do if you look at let's look at
what people do who have a disruptive
influence on society with their YouTube
channels and the vlogs and all of that
and let's use that because that is a way
I see to my my two youngest kids are 15
and 13 they get informed through YouTube
and in an incredible way and then they
come to me and dad is this true etc
sadly it's often not true so we have a
big discussion with it which is good but
I I agree with you we need to put this
material out there in forms that can be
shared by young people in a way that is
natural and not just because teacher
tells you to so I I fully agree we need
to learn teach us and we'll do it yes
I know thank you
first of all I'd like to thank you for
fighting so hard for this because this
is one of the few sparks of hope at what
has been dug the least ambitious couple
so far I have some questions in regards
to the transportation sector so
regarding the aviation industry there is
no mention about for instance v80 on
kerosene or theity on flight tickets or
tacks on kerosene and the e.t.s credits
that are given out for free it only
mentions a reduction how are you going
to ensure that the aviation industry
will pay their fair share in fighting
climate change they're not paying their
fair share now and they should and that
is we have a number of the measures we
can take first of all three missions we
need to look at that and tighten that
considerably secondly the ETS system
needs to be reinforced I think also
beyond what I hater is proposing and we
need to have a discussion about that
thirdly and this is something I've been
saying for more than a year in the
electoral campaign leading up to the
European elections and since and I will
not abandon that point
when you fill your car with petrol you
pay tax quite a lot of tax actually when
you take the train the train company has
to pay tax on the electricity that or
diesel that drives the train when you
take an airplane they don't pay tax on
the kerosene that is not right we need
to fix that
so I believe that there needs to be a
tax on kerosene I've been telling
airlines that but we need to make sure
that we don't create an unlevel we need
to make create a level playing field
which means we need to do this
internationally we can start as Europe
it's a big market and then we need to
convince others to do the same and the
revenue of this kerosene tax should be
directed at least in part directly at
climate measures directly so that we can
see that the money that comes in goes
directly to preparing us for a climate
mutual future in 2050 yes
[Music]
thank you
we seem to have another question over
there so the opportunity I feel very
grateful for this my name is Alberto and
Salif
I studied automotive engineering and I'm
here to raise my voice for a more
sustainable and efficient way to use
energy of transportation and precisely
in electric mobility and hydrogen power
right now the the biggest net and the
biggest company that makes superchargers
is private and the hydrogen way to
recharge the cars with hydrogen it's
almost non-existent
so I want to ask Europe to be the
leaders on hydrogen petrol hydrogen
stations and electricity stations and
that's a thing that we are I think we
only could do it by investing public
European money and not relying on the
private sector so I ask if this is
possible
how can we do it yes I could answer that
question for the next three to four
hours but I won't so I'll try and be
very very precise first of all we are
going to build 1 million charging
stations across the European Union
especially in places where the market
doesn't do it so in more remote places
you know the distance between charging
stations should be so acceptable that
people have no worries about running out
of electricity when they drive their
cars so we will be investing that
secondly I strongly believe in hydrogen
as an energy source for the future I
strongly believe in hydrogen different
mobility yes fuel cells in cars fueled
by hydrogen is part of our mobility
future but I also strongly believe in
hydrogen in another sense hydrogen could
be the energy recipient of solar and
wind energy and could then be
transported over distance and used
elsewhere the one check the challenge we
have with solar and wind energy is how
to store it batteries are not that are
just a very limited solution but
hydrogen can be a great way of storing
it and we have a lot of existing
infrastructure in Europe for gas for
natural gas that could be relatively
easily a restructured to be a network
for hydrogen and we could also for
instance have incredible agreements with
countries in Africa where solar cells do
not pose a threat to biodiversity if you
put them in the desert and those solar
cells could create hydrogen and this
hydrogen could then again be the new
energy source for Africa and other parts
of the world
so yes Europe needs to be the world
leader in developing hydrogen
as an energy for the future thank you
one more question perhaps please do
speak into the microphone so that we can
hear you
we're trying to go around the stage good
day my name is Laura Ruiz I study
industrial organization and
environmental engineering I'm I'm going
back to something that has been said
before how important the land is our
land is at the space we build on we ride
on and we eat from and we often forget
that it's right beneath our feet so I
have a question for you I'd like to know
how much discussion there is in Europe
about the quality of soil because it's
not just the ground we're standing on
it's it's the land and the soil
everywhere in Europe so how how deeply
do you study do you do land studies are
there professionals working in Europe to
protect our land and our soil basically
we use all the expertise across the
European Union and you know use academia
and other expertise to give us advice on
how to organize this but I want to make
a point too
about why we need to change for decades
our agricultural policy was directed at
one thing feed Europeans as cheaply as
possible with good quality foods in this
order and then because energy was not an
issue transportation was not an issue we
did look at other issues enough and now
we have to come back I believe to other
issues where do you produce in a natural
way in the most efficient way
how can you produce close to the
consumer so that you don't need to
transport foodstuffs over a long time so
you don't need to pack them and package
them in plastics so you don't use an
enormous storm of carbon footprints to
bring things to the table all these
elements will have to be part of
agricultural policy of the future and we
will be asking member states every
single member state make a plan for
sustainable agriculture for bio-based
agriculture tell us how you can be
ecologically sound with your agriculture
and then we will assess those plans and
on the basis of the assessment of those
plans we will see to what extent that
Member States can be part of the
subsidies in the Common Agricultural
Policy
that's not yes thank you very much
there's another question here hello my
I'm member of extinction rebellion and
we're asking for the creation of
citizens assemblies on a national and
European level in order to make binding
solutions as to how to solve the climate
crisis in the last 50 years we've
collected that data on the serious
situation of the climate crisis we've
had the possibility to fight it from a
technological level but this has a
midden because of the lack of a
political willingness so we need other
tools that we'll be able to bring a
quick a change and we believe that
citizens assemblies can be very
efficacious in order to bring about this
change and also like to say that 2050 is
not enough an extension rebellion and
all the groups who will keep on that
putting pressure in order for this
process to speed up thank you very much
edition and as a as the official of the
Commission and I thank you for that
you know as a professor in the past when
I talk to you guys
I was always criticizing I said you are
the healthiest strongest best educated
generation in European history you have
the best ideas you're driven by idealism
not ideology idealism it's all very good
but you think it's enough to put your
ideas on Facebook and then it will
happen it's not that our society works
so now since two years you have taught
me that you can be different since two
years what I see is young people getting
more and more organized but what you're
not there yet so take the success of the
last two years and then think about the
next level the ideas you're putting on
the table now could be part of the next
level
what could also be part of the next
level is that you look at existing
structures and then take over those
structures and then reform them in your
image or create alternative structures
that can be attractive to the citizens
at the end of the day the democracy it
will depend where the citizens will
support you or not whether they will
trust you or not and for that you need
to mobilize as many people as possible
for that you need organization you need
communication skills you need support
and anything I could do in advice
anything or giving you a platform when
you think you need it you can come to me
and we will offer you a platform to
propose that or to propagate that but at
the end of the day it will depend on
your organizational skills whether you
get this done society is ready for it
it's ready for it it's ready for it if
Time magazine
you know is ready to say that a 16 year
old girl is Person of the Year then
something is coming you guys are coming
and make sure that you do what is
necessary that we take the right
decisions so that we jointly can look
forward to a climate neutral 2015 meter
of the champ oh yeah mucho 11 second
active we're running out of time and
there are many questions that maybe we
won't have time to take them all but
would like to ask you to share them all
in Twitter or Facebook or with hashtags
like a EU dialogue so rest we won't have
enough time we will have one last
question here hello my name is Thomas
here Scott and I believe that people
really want to make the right choices we
are all trying to work towards a better
world
however for consumers it is so difficult
to do what's right when I walk into a
supermarket I don't know if one type of
milk is metella and another or if I buy
a car I might know how much of the myths
but I have no idea how much co2 was used
in producing it or shipping it around
the world and therefore I want
what is your opinion on producing a co2
label so that consumers can be aware of
everything they buy or every mode of
transportation they use that they know
exactly if what they're doing is good
for the environment
well that's an incredibly good question
first of all I think carbon footprints
should be reflected not just on the
label but also on the price so I think
we collectively need to change our
taxation systems so that products with a
bigger carbon footprints are taxed
heavier and products with a smaller
carbon footprint so then you already
influence the behavior of consumers but
especially also of industry because they
will try and produce with at least the
smallest possible carbon footprint on
top of that I think labeling is very
important the European Union years ago
already introduced energy labeling you
know that to demonstrate the energy
efficiency of products in the beginning
people were skeptical saying oh it's too
complicated I don't understand now it is
commonplace people are used to it
so we will have to introduce that sort
of labeling also in other areas not just
in terms of the carbon footprint of
industrial products or consumer goods
especially also of what we eat of the
food we eat of agricultural products and
I know that many parts of for instance a
retail know that they need to do this
retail is ready to work with us to do
this we need better informed consumers
and it's not just that it's also when
people want to change the energy of
their houses because they know that
their house isn't isolated they would
like to isolate it they would like to
have solar panels but they can't afford
it so we need to make it affordable we
need
make sure that they can sign a contract
with a smaller medium-sized enterprise
that would put solar panels or a heat
pump in isolate the house put other
window panes in and then the energy bill
will not change you say that company
would say to the citizen you will pay
the same amount you've been paying until
now to me and over five six years you
will have paid off everything and then
it's yours and you pay only the
maintenance costs of nothing else this
is how you get citizens to embrace the
idea because I run into many people who
say you're right we need to do this but
it's too complicated it's too scary I
don't know how I don't know who to trust
and we need to build trust so that
people embrace the future and are not
afraid of it and if I can end on this
because this is the last thing I can say
guys my biggest worry is not the climate
deniers they are you know almost
disappearing even even Jeremy Clarkson
no longer denies climate change so you
know that's a very small group my
biggest worry are the people who think
it's hopeless
the people who say okay climate is
changing it's going to be bad but what
can I do what can I do let's live it out
for a couple of years and we need to
prevent people becoming desperate or
hopeless and show that we can do this we
can fix this and let's show them that we
will fix it with your help and I'm sure
we can get there thanks you very much
thank you very much for the time
Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
muchas gracias Anatole oh thank you very
much on behalf of the participants mr.
Frane Simmons would like to have a
picture taken with all of you I know
it's gonna be difficult
luckily we have some wonderful
professionals here and the best way to
do it is that we're going to ask mr.
Timmerman said to step down and the rest
of you please come close to him from
behind in order to see how many people
can fit in the photo and let's go for it
it's Adamo's in spacio hockey what's
happenin hands
Eric what does MOSFET